روسيا تنفذ غارات استثنائيه على مدن اخرى
عقب اول نجاح اوكراني في جبهه بخموت
اصابه فلسطيني مجروح باقتحام الجيش
الاسرائيلي لمخيم عقبه جبر في اريحاوله
اعتقالات في الضفه والقدس
اردوغان يعقد اجتماعا لتقييم دوره
الانتخابات الاولى وانباء عن اقاله في حزب
الشعب
[موسيقى]
نبدا بهذا الخبر من السودان حيث افاد
مراسل العربيه من دراع اشتباكات في مناطق
اركويت والمعموره والصحافه شرق الخرطوم
وجبر جنوبا العاصمه السودانيه
الى اوكرانيا مشاهدينا حيث نفذت روسيا
غارات جويه استثنائيه كما وصفت فجر اليوم
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه اخرى خلفت جرحى
ثلاثه اشخاص على الاقل هذا الهجوم هو ثامن
على كييف منذ مطلع الشهر مايو الجاري هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه اكدت ان روسيا استخدمت
في الهجوم المعقد طائرات بدون طيار
وصواريخ كروس وربما صواريخ باليستيه الجيش
الاوكراني اكد بهذا السياق اسقاط 18
صاروخا روسيا في الهجوم وذكرت مصادر
اوكرانيه انفجارات واقعه في احياء عده
بالعاصمه في الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم
فيما اوضح رئيس بلديه كيا في تاليتشكو ان
الحطام الناجمه سقط على حديقه للحيوانات
في كييف
مشاهدينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا
بك حذيفه معلومات او فاذا عن هذه الغارات
طبيعه التي طالتها وايضا لماذا وصفت هذه
الغارات بالاستثنائيه
نعم اهلا بك احمد في الحقيقه وصفت هذه
الغارات بال النهائيه لان الهجوم كان
متزامنا من عده جهات من الشمال ومن الجنوب
ومن الشرق في وقت متزامن نحو العاصمه كيف
ايضا كان هنالك سته صواريخ من طراز خنجر
التي يقول الروس انه يصعب او شبه المستحيل
اسقاطها واستطعت قوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان تسقط سته صواريخ من طراز خنجر او كنجال
ومجموعه الصواريخ التي اطلقت 18 صاروخا
كان ذلك في حوالي الساعه الثالثه والنصف
صباحا اليوم وجهت نحو العاصمه كيف في وقت
متزامن ايضا تم اطلاق عدد من المسيرات حتى
الان الدفاع الجوي لم يحدد عدد المسيرات
التي تم اطلاقها نحو العاصمه كيف بالاضافه
الى اطلاق ايضا طائرات يعني استطلاع من
طراز اورلاند
لكشف مواقع الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه في
العاصمه كيف هذه الضربه التي وجهت او
الغاره التي نحو العاصمه اكيد لم تخلف وسط
المدنيين اي قتله او جرحه حتى الان بحسب
افاده عمده المدينه وقائد الاداره
العسكريه للعاصمه اكيد ولكن خلفت بعض من
الدمار في بعض من الشوارع في السيارات
للمواطنين ايضا تضررت هنالك منزل وحيد
احترق في ضواحي العاصمه وهو منزل خشبي
طبعا بعد ان سقط جزء من الصاروخ وكان
محترقا واحترق المنزل بطبيعه الحال ودائما
في الفتره الاخيره نلاحظ ان اي سقوط لجزء
من صاروخ في ضواحي المدينه حيث البيوت
الخشبيه دائما ما يحدث حريق ويكون هنالك
اثار كبيره ولكن في الفتره الاخيره في وسط
العاصمه كيف بعد ان اصبح الدفاعات الجويه
يمكن ان نقول بنسبه 100 في المئه في اخر
ثلاث غارات وجهت نحو العاصمه كيف استطاعت
ان تسقط جميع الصواريخ والضربات ماعدا في
حاله وحيده تم يعني هنالك صاروخ وحيد
استطاع ان يصل الى هدفه نسبه الدفاعات
الجويه ونسبه كفاءه الدفاعات الجويه في
العاصمه كيف ارتفعت بشكل كبير جدا حيث
اصبح يعني
المدينه اصبحت سمائها اصبحت محميه بشكل
اكبر لا يوجد اضرار تذكر في داخل المدينه
كما قلت هنالك بعض الشظايا سقطت في بعض
المناطق
حذيفه شكرا لك منك كنت معنا مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل تحياتي
افاد مراسل العربيه بان الجيش الاوكراني
استهدف مدينه وضواحيها بثلاثمائه وتسعه
صواريخ وقذيفه مدفعيه ما اسفر عن مقتل شخص
واصابه تسعه اخرين بجروح كما ادى القصف
يعتبر 10 ابنيه سكنيه وخمسه مرافق بنا
تحتيه وبينما يتواصل القتال على جبهه
بخموت سخر رئيس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست زعم انه عرض على كييف
معلومات حول مواقع القوات الروسيه مقابل
انسحابها ووصف بريغوجي التقرير من المضحك
مرجحا ان يكون افرادا من النخبه الروسيه
وراء تسريبه اما فوصف المعلومات التي
نشرتها واشنطن بوست بالمضلله
وفي اول اعتراف رسمي ببد هجوم الربيع كشف
قائد قوات البريه الاوكرانيه
على المناطق التي تسيطر عليها روسيا شمالا
وشرق البلاد مزيد من التفاصيل في التقرير
التالي
من فيلم بل الاختراق خطوط دفاع الجيش
الروسي على اطراف ضخمه خطوط قال قائد قوه
فاجنر ان الجنود الروسي يفيرون منها
فوفق لقائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
فان قواته تتقدم في ضخمه كاول نجاح في
الهجوم الايام القليله الماضيه اظهرت انه
يمكننا المضي قدما وتدمير العدو حتى في
مثل هذه الظروف الصعبه للغايه نقاتل
بموارد اقل من العدو وفي الوقت نفسه ننجح
في تدمير خططه
تصريح سيرسكي يعتبر اول اعتراف رسمي ببدء
هجوم الربيع هجوم تقول المعلومات انه لا
يقتصر على باخبز فقط فالقوه الاوكرانيه
قصفت اراضي دانيتسكي 90 مره خلال الاربع
والعشرين ساعه الماضيه وفي المجموع اطلقت
500 وسته عشره قذيفه على المنطقه التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا من جانبها اعترفت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بمقتل اثنين من قادتها
العسكريين شرق اوكرانيا اثناء اختراق
القوات الاوكرانيه الدفاعات الروسيه في
باخمت موسكو اعترفت ايضا بان قواتها
تراجعت في شمال المدينه وسط تكثيف للهجمات
الاوكرانيه في تقرير لوزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه فان مسيرات شنت هجوما على
قاعده جويه روسيه على بعد 150 كيلومترا
شمال الحدود الاوكرانيه في الثالث من مايو
مرجحت الوزاره في التقرير ان يكون الهجوم
اضر باحدى طائرات النقل الثقيل حيث لعبت
القاعده الروسيه دورا رئيسيا في التقدم
الذي احرزته موسكو في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
عاد كون القاعده تستخدمها لاطلاق المسيرات
الايرانيه باتجاه كيف
وبين تكتم كييف على بدء الهجوم وما تقوله
المعلومات على الارض تبدو افاده قائد قوات
فاجنر الاخيره اقرب للواقع حين قال كيف
حصلت على الاسلحه
وبدات هجومها
[تصفيق]
تناقش وزيره انتقال الطاقه الفرنسيه
في باريس اليوم تناقش مع نظرائها من اربع
عشره دوله في الاتحاد الاوروبي وبريطانيا
وسيناقش وزراء الطاقه في اطار التحالف
الدول الاوروبيه للطاقه في مارس السوبر
الممكنه لتعزيز استقلال اوروبا عن روسيا
لا سيما في مساله الوقود النووي والتي لا
يمكن القيام بها بين عشيه وضحاها لان بعض
الدول لديها محطات طاقه روسيه على اراضيها
وهذا يزيد الاعتماد على الوقود من روسيا
يذكر ان الاتحاد الاوروبي استورد العام
الماضي وقودا النووي من روسيا بمبلغ مليار
يورو حسب صحيفه
اقتحمت القوات الاسرائيليه صباح اليوم
مخيم عقبه جبر جنوب غرب اريحا حيث حاصرتها
بل حاصرت منزلا وطالبتا في منفيه بتسليم
انفسهم الاقتحام الاسرائيلي تسبب في اصابه
فلسطيني برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي والعشرات
بالاختناق بالغاز بالقوات الاسرائيليه
اعتقد سته شبان فلسطيني خلال اقتحام
المخيم وبلغ عدد الاعتقالات عشرين فلسطيني
الليله الماضيه في عده مناطق بضفه غربيه
والقدس
مشاهدينا برام الله معنا مراسله العربيه
خالد القاسم اهلا بك خالد وهل ما زالت
عمليه الاقتحام ومحاصره المنزل جاري حتى
اللحظه
لا انتهت من وجهه النظر الجيش الاسرائيلي
الهدف من العمليه تم تحقيقه باعتقال من
تقول اسرائيل بانهم مطلوبين لاجهزه الامن
الاسرائيليه والذين تحصنوا داخل منزل في
مخيم عقبه جبر بالقرب من مدينه اريحا حيث
حصلت قوات كبيره من الجيش المنزل وكان
هناك تبادل لاطلاق النار سواء من داخل
المنزل او من محيط المنزل مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي ادى الى اصابه فلسطيني برصاصه
في الفخذ وصفت اصابته طفيفه الى متوسطه
كما افضت العمليه الى اعتقال سته
فلسطينيين واصابه عدد اخر من الفلسطينيين
بالاختناق جراء استنشاق الغاز المسيل
للدموع نفس المشهد كان في بلده قباطها الى
الشمال من مدينه جنين جنوب الضفه شمال
الضفه الغربيه حيث عفوا مدينه قباطيه جنوب
مدينه
قبل نهايه الاسبوع بين اردوغانو
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نسالف نشره من
تركيا حيث عقدت اللجنه التنفيذيه المركزيه
لحزب العداله والتنميه التركي اجتماعا
برئاسه زعيم الحزب الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
في العاصمه انقره الاجتماع الذي انعقد
بعيدا عن وسائل الاعلام واستغرق ثلاث
ساعات خصوص لتقييم الانتخابات البرلمانيه
والرئاسيه الاخيره التي شهدتها تركيا كما
ناقشت تحضيرات اللازمه للجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات في 28 من مايو جاري
وكان اردوغان قال في بيان الله ان شعبه ان
شعبه انجز انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه والتي
تعد على حد وصفه واحده من الانتخابات
الاكثر مشاركه في تاريخ البلاد مؤكدا ان
الاصوات التي حصل عليها ستضاعف وسيحقق
فوزا تاريخيا في جوله الاعاده
وبخصوص منافس
اردوغانو افادت مصادر تركيا معارضه انه
طلب من نائمه في حزب الشعب الجمهوري
الاستقاله بسبب ادائه السلبي في
الانتخابات
وهو نائب كريستيانو نشر تغريده اكد فيها
قرار الاستقاله حتى لا يؤثر على حظوظك
الذي نشر مقطع فيديو على حسابه في تويتر
قال فيه انه سيناقس بل انه سيقاتل حتى
النهايه على حد وصفه
هذا وينتظر ان يكشف المرشح الرئاسي سنان
اوغان قبل نهايه الاسبوع عن المرشح الذي
سيدعمه اوغان اضاف ان هناك خطوطا حمره
وشروطا على راسها مكافحه الارهاب
والابتعاد عن الاحزاب السياسيه التي
تدعمها التنظيمات الارهابيه بالاضافه الى
ترحيل اللاجئين
المعركه الانتخابيه التركيه الى جوله
ثانيه واقتصارها على المنافسين بل على
المتنافسين كمالك شجر اوغلو ورجب طيب
اردوغان كيف سيسعى كل منهما لحسم السباق
لصالح خلال الاسبوعين المقبلين
اسبوعان امام رجب طيب اردوغان ومنافسه
كمال كيلشدار اوغلو باستماله الاصوات وكسب
المعركه في الجوله الثانيه
المعارضه برئاسه
في سياستها على انهاء حقبه اردوغان
و وحلفاؤه يريدون تغيير النظام الرئاسي
وتقليص صلاحيات الرئيس اغلاق المشاريع
الكبرى مثل قناه اسطنبول وصندوق الثروه
التركي
تحويل البلاد الى منطقه عازله وزياده عدد
مراكز اعاده اللاجئين واعاده السوريين
انهاء نظام ايداع الليره المحمي واعفاء
الشباب من رسوم جواز السفر وعود اردوغان
اردوغان يركز على سياسه دعم فئه الشباب
الداخليا وقطاع التعليم وزياده اشراك
المراه في القوه العامله
وعود بتدابير جديده لمعالجه التضخم
وانهيار الليره التركيه
خارجيا يريد اردوغان اتباع سياسه الانفتاح
اكثر على الدول المنطقه والعالم
السباق بين المتنافسين في المرحله القادمه
يتطلب استقطاب اصوات نخيبي الخارجي من
الجوله الاولى
سنان اوغان ومحرم انجا قد يشكلان ورقه
الفوز في الجوله القادمه بالتحالف مع
احدهما
اذا كما اسفنا القول اسبوعا يحاسبان
يفصلان اردوغانو عن جوله ختاميه تقرر من
سيحكم تركيا لكن كيف سيكسب المتنافسان
مزيدا من الاصوات للظفر بالسباق
من يفصلان
اردوغانو عن جوله ختاميه يقرر من سيحكم
تركيا للفتره المقبله في جوله انتخابات
رئاسيه ثانيه تعد الاولى في تاريخ تركيا
التي تتزامن طبعا ويتزامن اجراؤها مع
الذكرى المئه لتاسيس البلاد كجمهوريه عقب
انهيار الامبراطوريه العثمانيه نسبه
المشاركه مشاهدينا كانت قياسيه وغير
مسبوقه وصلاه الى
89% ولكن ما الذي سيفعله اردوغان خلال
هذين الاسبوعين لاقناع الناخبين بضروره
استمراره رئيسا للبلاد اولا يواجه الرجل
اي اردوغان صعوبات وتحديات لجذب كتله
ناخبه جديده تحسم المنافسه لصالحه لان
اولويه الناخب التركيه اليوم هي مواجهه
الصعوبات الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه التي فشلت
فيها سياسات اردوغان الغير معهوده
اقتصاديا وهنا يراهن اردوغان على شعبيته
بين الناخبين الريفي
والطبقه العامله والمتدينين الذين ينسبون
اليه الفضل بتطوير البلاد وتعزيز مكانتها
الدوليه خلال العشرين سنه الماضيه ايضا
سيعمل اردوغان على استقطاب اصوات مناصري
المرشح الثالث وهو سنان الحاصل بحسب
النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات على 5% من
الاصوات بحسب طبعا النتائج الرسميه حيث من
المرجح ان يفضله اتباع اوجان القوميين
اليمينيين تقول هنا صحيفه نيويورك تايس
هذا كان عن اردوغان ولكن ماذا عن اوغلو
اوغلو هو مرشح المعارضه سيستغل نقاط ضعف
خصمه اردوغان لكسب اصوات مناصريه
والمترددين ايضا كما سيعمل زعيم المعارضه
لتعزيز خطابه الانتخابيه والاجتماعي
والاقتصادي الذي نجح فيه الى حد كبير بنيل
ثقه الاتراك بطبيعه الحال كالجدار اوغلو
لن ينسى ورقته الرابحه والتي عززت طبعا
حضوره وصوتت لصالحه خلال مختلف المحطات
الانتخابيه واعطته هذه المره 20% من
الاصوات الناخبه هذه الورقه هي الاكراد
طبعا
استقبل وزير خارج السعوديه الامير فيصل
فرحان نظيرته الالمانيه في جده وعربت
بيربو عن شكري وتقدير بلادها لما قامت به
المملكه من عمليات اجلاء لرعايه المانيا
من السودان منوهه بالكفاءه العاليه للجهات
السعوديه في نجاح هذه العمليات وعقد
الجانب جلسه مباحثات رسميه تطرقت لسبل
تعزيز جهود البلدين في ارساء دعائم السلام
بالمنطقه والعالم
اكاد رئيس الوزراء اليمني مواعيد عبد
الملك حرصه حكومته على اتاحه الفرصه
الجهود الرامي لانهاء الحرب في البلاد جاء
ذلك خلال اجتماع لعبد الملك مع بعثه
وسفراء عدد من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي لدى
اليمن حيث اشار رئيس الوزراء للتنازلات
التي قدمتها الشرعيه في مسار الهدنه
بالرغم من حصار الحوثيين لتعز وانتهاكاتهم
متكرره التي تعمق معانته اليمنيين هذا
وحذر رئيس الوزراء الياباني من خطوره تغ
اضي المجتمع الدولي عن الاجراءات الاحاديه
التي يمارسها الحوثيون ضد اقتصاد البلاد
والبنوك في المناطق الخاضعه لسيطرتهم
بيان صادر عن الجيش الباكستاني عقب اجتماع
ضمه قاده فياليقه باعمال التخريم والشغب
التي تعرضت لها مرافقه وتوعد مخططي او
منفني هذه الاعتداءات بالمحاكمه وفق
القوانين الباكستانيه والقانون العسكري
اصدرت السلطات الامريكيه مذكره استدعاء
بحق ايلون ماسك الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
تسلا في قضيه مصر في جيب مارجان شيس
المتهم بمساعده ملياردير في تنظيم شبكه
لتهريب البشر وتشير الوثائق القضائيه التي
تم نشرها الى ان سلطته الامريكيه حاولت
تسليم ماسك مذكره استدعاء صادره في 28 من
ابريل
لاشتباهتين قد يكون اشار الى ايلون ماسك
كزبون لمصيف جيب مورغن وقالت سلطه انها
تحاول تحديد مكان
وفي نهايه النشر مشاهدينا نذكر بابرز
العناوين
روسيا تنفذ غارات استثنائيه على كيا ومدن
اخرى عقب اول ناجح اوكراني في جبهه
باقتحام الجيش الاسرائيلي مخيم عقبه جابر
في اريحا وحمله اعتقالات في الضفه والقدس
اردوغان يعقد اجتماعا لتقييم دوره
الانتخابات الاولى وانباء عن اقاله نائب
كريستال في حزب الشعب
نهايه هذه النشره المشاهدين شكرا لحسين
المتابع وللمزيد يمكنكم الانتقال الى
العربيه
كونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات